home from college again yo what's the
Wi-Fi I need to log in it's funny how
you've been showing up here every 31
days yeah it's hilarious
who's that oh an old friend of yours I I
thought you knew him hiya pal uh yeah
good friends uh you know I'm in kind of
a rush so I'm just going to log into my
Netflix real quick oh [__]
do you think stealing is funny you
wouldn't steal a car if you can afford
weed you can afford your own Netflix
account
so you'll get your own account no I'm
just gonna pirate things again you you
will yeah it's not worth the money plus
you canceled most of my favorite shows
oh
kidding what psych
I can't just say psych I can and I did